The federal high tech program supported the development of state HIEs.
As a result of that,
of growing EHR adoption,
and of the data sharing requirements of meaningful use,
2015 addition of a survey sponsored by
the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation reported that as of 2014,
76 percent of hospitals were exchanging data with outside health professionals,
including ambulatory health professionals and other hospitals.
This was up from 62 percent in 2013 and 41 percent 2008.
The shared data might include laboratory results,
radiology reports, clinical care summaries, or medications.
Despite this growth HIEs reported many barriers.
Only 46 percent of our operational HIEs and 38 percent of HIE efforts
in the planning stage reported that they were able to
cover our operating costs with revenue from participants.
This has long been an ongoing issue with HIEs.
So we will now consider how technology might make them more
sustainable or possibly unnecessary in the future.